foreign
[Music]
oh dude when does this come out Thursday
I'm in Vegas I'm in Vegas actually
you're here you're there too yeah yeah
I'm doing shows in Vegas I'm doing shows
in Charlotte I got Brea I got Irvine
coming up I got uh uh
uh I said Charlotte Knoxville Little
Rock Arkansas Denver no not Denver sorry
about that
um I don't know a bunch of different
cities go to chrislea.com uh but yeah
welcome to the new episode of
congratulations
[Music]
awesome and we have my guest
which is you know she's the best needs
no introduction especially to the people
who are Avid listeners because you make
an appearance pretty much on every
episode even if you're not physically on
it because I talk about you my wife
Kristen Taylor
now babe what we do is
um we have a new thing where we start
the podcast with a few minutes of
laughing because I'm getting absolutely
jacked oh sorry can you explain
like just like this which is funny
because I you know I I do I'm always
broad right but when I start working out
you know I get crazy into it no I know
Gotta Get Crazy into it and I'm beefed
up
what the what the frick you know
um because I don't swear but uh I
actually
um worked out today no [__] way okay
so we're gonna have to bleep that out
because it's the beginning of the
episode she doesn't know the rules and
that's fine oh that's kind of right
though so it's gonna do the beep
whatever it is
okay we can remember to quiet it out
because uh we don't mean it but we don't
mean to uh what do you call it stifle
you what do we call censor you
but yeah we can because we get to
monetized but but we can swear after
like five minutes isn't that crazy my
man dude so I worked out today and guess
what happened
you got extra swole no well yeah but I I
pulled my back a little bit in the
middle of it he's old folks I am old
dude and what did I do I kept going and
you kept complaining as I knew you would
sweetheart I kept going dude I kept
going not only did I keep going I kept
doing the same exercise I go like this
oh
no nobody let's keep going and I did you
got to listen to your body I know that's
your body telling you you got to stop
and I wonder if it was a mistake we'll
find out tomorrow when we wake up well
tomorrow we'll find out if my back still
hurts or Worse um but anyway yeah I
don't I'm not gonna stop dude you see
these from dead lifting anyway dude
enough about me
how are you I know good good we talk
every day but you know not on the
podcast so yeah uh what's been going on
I listened to about 50 of them
I'm a mom of two we got a lot going on
you should force the kids to listen but
the kids to the podcast yeah I don't
think this is like kid appropriate no
okay no
um but what what kinds of things do you
say on the podcast about me yeah are
they nice oh oh yeah always I always say
you're my angel and then I talk about
how I always feel like that's weird to
say you're my angel because you're just
an angel that was put on Earth you know
and I'm lucky enough to be around you
makes me feel like a simp just talk it
like that because I never used to talk
like that but really when you realize
that stuff you got to say it because you
got to be who you are sure right
um but anyway whatever I don't really
know what a simp is yeah it's like a
simp like a guy that'll do anything to
get a chick yeah there's so much of the
lingo it's funny like growing up and you
you hear your parents saying the dumb
things oh that was like a decade ago
like my dad is like the king of that
like he'll be like what up homie yeah
rolling with my homies yeah they'll be
like oh 50 Cent remember what dude one
of the things that bothered me the most
is when people said 50 Cent when white
people said 50 Cent and they would say
50 Cent because it's you're making it
racist right whoever does that is racist
oh okay
um remember when we were listening to
the podcast last night and the guy said
just the one that we are listening to
and the guy said ambulance oh yeah he
did ambulance Amber Lamps ambulance he
was black I'm all sad I know you're not
going to do it but he was black black
people say Amber Lamps and the library
and I don't know why it's just in their
culture it's part of the culture
um but yeah dude ambulance it actually
should be ambulance
I agree with black people it should not
be library though okay because that
sounds like a fruit but Amber Lamps 100
should be that because it's it's at
least ambulance sounds so clinical amble
amps sounds awesome it's me it's Amber
Lamps I'll turn off sort of Amber Lamps
sounds awesome because at least if
someone's dying you get to be like the
ambulance is coming in it's fun to say
yeah I think he had a stroke but don't
worry the Amber Lamps is coming
dude that's awesome wow I hope well I
don't hope we don't have to I hope we
have to call the ambulance soon but not
on us
you want to call them on somebody yeah
you want
randomly on someone yeah sometimes when
I need a break you want to call it you
want an ambulance what just like a ride
with some peace and quiet just away from
my family this is a great one
and I'd send you the bill oh and I hurt
my back so wow yeah I don't think it's a
big I don't think it's like a bulging
disc or anything like that so you know
how you're going on about ambulance and
what was the other word a library
you think so deeply about these odds oh
okay so here we go this is going to be
not a compliment it seems like a
compliment but it's gonna be not a
compliment welcome to my wife's world go
ahead okay I'll rephrase it so it's
complimentary no it's okay I like it the
way it is you be you okay
you [__] suck
nice hat you suck I didn't have a hat on
you think so deeply about these minute
things in life that have no meaning that
don't matter
and will not affect anyone or anything
ever ambulance simply that thing that
you thought so deeply about will never
affect anyone or anything why don't you
want to focus that energy onto things
that could not only better you benefit
the world but but yeah you could be like
a I'm not a doctor I'm not a doctor you
could be a mayor
you could like do some things I could be
a mayor you know I could be Americans I
could do this
oh that would look good on a poster
right I was ready to slam but you did
look kind of cute dude so I could be a
mayor but I don't I don't think I could
be a mayor
because I don't think that I think I
would blow it like very early on and I I
would just I would get so pissed off
yeah and I would be like I'm I made the
[__] point you know if you don't get
it then you don't [__] get it and
then you would just be like superimposed
the this the stats going down over my
face yeah I don't I don't think I can be
mayor
well imagine like me if you were like
doing a speech at the podium and how
embarrassed I would be you'd be so proud
and then immediately so wrecked yeah so
much like smiling like crying yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah trying to keep it
together and then I come up if I really
wanted to do it yeah but but it's crazy
black people say ambulance oh I would
say at the end you know what being with
you is like what it's like you know the
owners that have the dogs that they love
but they like bite little kids in public
or they bark too much yeah and you have
them out and you love them so deeply but
you're constantly apologizing for them
you're like sorry he's just like that's
right that's me being in a relationship
with you I'm like I'm sorry it's just
like kind of a little bit yeah and then
I go like this she doesn't
do well you have a thing where you talk
you feel like you want everyone to be
okay and like
everything's fine yeah yeah a bull could
like literally like Crush into our
living room and you'll be like do you
want any anything to eat to the bull you
know what I mean like you just I don't
want
yeah which is a problem in itself and
something that I need to work on and
that's why we make a great couple and
that's why we also butt head sometimes
because you want everyone to be okay and
I want everyone to die and I I'm a
nihilist
uh yeah but I don't know speaking of you
thinking about things oddly we had a
conversation this morning and I cannot
stop thinking about it and maybe we can
talk about it here oh really it's crazy
that two people can have something that
happens and the and one person could be
thinking about it Non-Stop and the other
person is just like we talked in the
morning I thought I just got up
and and went to the gym but what
happened I was so excited to talk to you
about it I had to stop myself from going
upstairs and wake you up and when I
heard your little feedsteps I was like
oh dude this this was ridiculous how you
woke I woke up dude okay let me just
start by saying when I wake up I don't
I'm awake
I'm not ready period I gotta hang out
for like at least 40 minutes I don't
open my actual eyes yeah for 30 minutes
I'm walking around one eyes open to you
know I mean like I'm like halfway yeah
dude you wanted to wake me up for that
yeah unbelievable I'm walking down I'm
not even downstairs yet okay
this is what happens go ahead now you
can go no I want to hear it from your
perspective first and then I'll correct
dude okay I walk down the stairs she is
at the bottom of the stairs already okay
inner in one of her nine rows all right
it's blue right the blue one you had to
blue one on I had the pink one on God
damn it memory so I she's you really had
to pick one on I don't know I think
you're the blue one on well I guess
we'll find out upstairs when it's on the
bed you think you had to pick one on
yeah wow
that's crazy in my head it's blue that's
really crazy all right so so I'm she's
at the bottom of the stairs I'm walking
down the stairs I'm not down the stairs
I'm halfway down the stairs exactly
halfway down the stairs yeah and she
says
babe and I said yep and she says
I think I know what you have
is this what you're talking about right
if you woke me up for this I say and I
know I go like this huh
but very groggy you know because I'm not
awake yet and she says
I said huh and she says I think I know
what you have you know how you sometimes
think that you're autistic and I and I
and I'm no you know I don't mean that to
troll people who have autism I think
that you know they have some of the most
beautiful Minds in the world yeah I mean
and then you know there's both ends
sometimes it's great sometimes it's not
great right but um
I I I wonder sometimes if I'm on the
Spectrum right uh
uh she says you know how you think you
have autism sometimes I think I know
what you do have
PDA right and I said public displays of
affection I don't like doing that but
that's not what she's talking about
she's talking about
it's like a sect of autism the PDA type
so and it's on the Spectrum
most of the people that have PDA are
autistic
um but it's not recognized by the DSM
so I have a lot of things that the DSM
don't recognize that's true yeah yeah
that's true by the way they recognize
Horton don't they I know it's so weird
that sex addiction is that added yeah
let's talk about sex addiction so yeah
they take they have hoarding and [__]
and like they talk about gambling right
and I don't know if they have gambling
but well overeating it's like dude I
mean yeah if gambling is one sex is so
obviously one it's the same thing as
gambling Darren talks about it though
um yeah I know forever that's never
gonna happen insurance companies don't
want to pay for it he gets real dude he
gets real sometimes is that what you
think it is yeah sure and tell me they
don't want to have to pay for [__]
rehab and [__] that had to come out of
my pockets by the way speaking of
pockets we got the diving board right
here because the pockets stay deep dude
we got a diving board right there and it
says on the back pockets they stay deep
that's the merch you can get it at
chrysalia.com right there Pockets stay
deep it's as is absolutely illen
and so um what were we talking about
autism I guess we could look it up right
yeah let's look it up I was reading the
symptoms
and
reading and symptoms and he wasn't
saying anything and then I got to the
end
and then he just looked at me and you
said
I'm every one of those hold on Pete PJ
uh autism autism
but in adults
because childhood symptoms
so hold on what is PDA like in adults
individuals with PDA May engage a bit
you want to read it sure okay
individuals with PDA May engage in
behaviors that allow them to avoid these
demands such as withdrawing from
activities avoiding social situations
distracting the person who is placing
the demand
dude I hate doing stuff making excuses
for not doing something or even lying if
they are desperate enough to avoid them
so let me just let me just say something
what they're describing honestly is a
person no oh come on dude every guys
listen to this go like this I got PDX no
you think that that's everyone because
you're in your own head this is every
guy except David Sullivan
oh I'll do it man he's got true true
he's running from something you want him
to be running from something because
he's such like a lovely person yeah we
gotta have some Somebody's gotta I don't
when when everybody's hunky Dorian and
all that [__] donkey Dory yeah it's just
like not it's not okay
so yeah so that's PDA okay let's go
through these and see what you guys that
you have we just did no but these are
this is like a more
um specific okay highly intelligent
hilarious
need for autonomy and control yeah
resist demands of everyday life even
activities that the person enjoys
there's honestly no such thing as
demands of everyday life so yes oh god
um may not recognize hierarchy
uh I agree with that thank you for
making that list that I agree with sure
it uses fantasy yes as an escape to
avoid demands yes you go like this hey
can you clean the dishwasher and I go
like this sex
[Laughter]
like this you got
you got here just can you move the car I
go like this hmm oh I'm thinking of sex
sex
you got real problems huh what you got
real problems yeah talking to the mic
man all right especially when it's
slamming go ahead
um difficulty with emotional regulation
or mood swings
I I don't know if I yes yeah well anger
yes
um might appear interested in
socializing but has difficulty
interpreting social interactions or
situations yes I don't have that I know
what's up that's the opposite of that is
knowing what's up and I have that
the doctor be like this I don't know if
you have that one because you know
what's up oh wow
um impulsivity yes difficulty with
self-regulation
uh may have special interests or seems
to have a one-track mind yes
can become obsessive
no
[Laughter]
meltdowns or shutdowns shutdowns
so
um you go like this you go like this you
go like this you say can you do the
dishwasher and I go like this sex
I shut down
I just don't there's so many things like
that happen in copulation that happened
in our day-to-day life then I try to
understand playing horizontal with our
woman
this is the one track mind yeah dude you
have to get the job done yeah yeah
[Music]
playing with a partner
downwards European slope of titties
you know what I mean
dude some Europeans they have the tits
that go
like Persian shoes
and you go like this and the blue genie
comes out
how many of you see it in person
European slope titties yeah
probably not many
I always put those back
how do you put them back
that's stupid
dude I so do you think you have us or
not
celebrities
yeah I think I probably have it but dude
this is but this is honestly like it's
what this is like they're making
something everything they're making
everything something okay I think you're
generalizing like not wanting to like
the making demands thing and it's like
every guy wants that you have to know
that you are so far on that end of the
spectrum any time that someone even
has a tone where you they could be
telling you in your head what to do I
get it I mean even now I'm
you're already checked out
yeah we did this conversation and I
asked you which is so funny because it's
like making a demand I was like well
look look it up on your own time so that
you can and you know what I thought when
you said that when you're talking I said
she's doing the thing that she knows I
don't she just pointed out that I'm not
I'm like this and she's doing the thing
she's making me do something and she's
already [__] pointed out that I don't
like to do it I called the nerve in my
head the nerve and then I go yeah and
then I'm two people are you kidding me
yeah that's unbelievable what the [__]
are we gonna do I don't know man sex
is this normal in relationships or is
this like really on the bad end who
knows dude I don't know yeah I don't
either what I do know is we're great
together and
that's that
so let's Boop leave it alone poop
anyway dude it would make a lot of sense
back's feeling great it would make like
a lot of things in my head make sense
like the puzzle pieces I've been trying
to understand about you
puzzle pieces huh yeah
speaking of which why don't you like to
watch movies
dude we watch the movie last night
though yeah we did and you liked it well
you were interested in it I would say I
was interested in it too yeah it was
fine it was good though it was good I'm
starting to like it
but just a little
you don't like watching this stuff and I
get it but uh you stayed up and you
watched it and it was a movie called
sanctuary and it was I didn't know what
we were getting into when we turned it
on we turned it on it was crazy it was
wild but anyway
um
and uh the guy from girls is in it
what's his name he's so cute you said
he's cute I think he's so cute I don't
know I I didn't think that but like uh
I'm a guy and like I was shocked that
you said you thought he was like kind of
hot
why do you think you could always know
like who I'm going to find I don't know
I think I do and then you always like
hear Christopher Abbott I mean he's
definitely uh good looking dude but like
I was like I was shocked yeah I like
that he looks like a little Jewish yeah
you like smart yeah you like the guys
that look a little Jewish I do like Adam
Driver too then huh oh my God yeah is
that a yes leave you for him oh okay
straight up okay even though he's in
that movie 65. what's that mean oh the
movie 65 it was terrible oh but it's
okay I've been in bad movies
um
uh yeah so is he married Chris Adam
Driver yeah that's I don't know is he
married and Driver married probably not
Joanne Tucker cute he's married
oh oh she's in thank you wait she's in
is she an actress or no oh no she's not
in there she's a politician whoa whoa
whoa
damn that's rad we gotta get um
politicians we got to get into politics
we gotta get into politics what would be
your platform
enough enough
vote for me
so good hey hey enough
all right pack it up you have one minute
yeah to give the speech of a lifetime to
convince got it all these guys no I want
you to do a minute okay all right ready
set
that's my mouth it's not the thing I
gotta go like this I know I'm not the
president doesn't matter I'm not even
going to be in prison I'm not interested
in being the president we got a lot of
stuff to iron out all right and I'm not
even gonna talk about what okay because
you know what there's common sense and
then there's us we're not near common
sense as a whole Mass we need to be at
the level of common sense so I say to
you people of whatever
you know body I'm trying to govern
enough that's what I'm running on I'm
running on enough's enough dude and I'm
not saying I'm against certain types of
people or against certain types of ideas
what I am saying is I'm against not
being for common sense so ladies and
gentlemen and whoever else you may be
enough's enough vote for me that was
exactly a minute is that 52. and I would
get votes dude you don't think I would
get a vote I would get votes you don't
think I would get votes
how would I be running against though
you're my first I vote for you duh and
then at the end I go
I go like that well that was and then
they cut back to the people they go oh
that was pretty okay well I don't know
dude
you would get elected yeah I know dude
it's just like straight out it's just so
annoying especially because I've had a
scandal dude if you have had a scandal
you can you can on a politician level
explain because people are like what the
[__] is up with this guy and they go hmm
and then they go ah [__] it oh what that
and then that half the people have to
hate you right sure people don't have to
be like yeah but [__] he's making
sense you know I made so much sense in
that speech yeah anyway
uh you know what that actually made me
think I could actually do it let's do it
babe president or what no not president
I would love to be first lady
I would love picking out dishes
don't say that I hate every single time
I know but you always somehow speak into
existence who talks about death more me
or you me so then what are you talking
about yeah but not to like out into the
world I don't put it into the ethos oh
okay well I'll get suck it back in into
your body take it out of the mic and
suck it back into your body that's not
how things work it does in my brain
thank you
but I want to go on with the bit sure
I would love to get dishes and pick them
out for the White House is I get
a-s-s-i-n-i whatever the rest of the
word is okay but I want to decorate the
White House okay that's very
self-serving dude you want me to run the
country because you want to decorate the
Ice House
my my first speech as president
ladies and gentlemen
babe
you'd be in the back sweating no I'm in
the back like walking with the lamp yeah
yeah yeah with dishes trying to get out
of this I'm gonna decorate it anyway
dude
anyway man you know it's like so what
else is going on
dude you know what
um
let's look up how you like enter races
nah nah you're not into it nah that was
a demand and I have PDA do you know what
what I want to know is I have been
getting more fit okay and you say you
like me better when I'm not fit
true and true dude what is up with that
man what is up with that yeah tell me
about that because I don't believe you
know I don't believe people anyway right
yeah that's my childhood but what is the
deal with that because how could you
like somebody who's less fit okay
um
there's something about it's not
it's not how your body looks one way or
the other it's the the act of wanting to
go and constantly
take
make yourself look better it's like that
thing that's a less attractive that's a
uh turn off
it's not a turn off good
one it's not a turn off it's like um
it's
there's how about this there's something
very sexy about a guy that's like ah
[__] it I don't right I know I know I
know but it doesn't it make up for it if
after the guy takes off his shirt and
it's a road map
to where
sexville
no okay
no well
I love the thing I like about it is that
you've found something that you really
really love and like watching you like
you're so obsessed with it right now
that like anytime I look at you yeah
you're just like obsessing about finding
workouts and planning what you're gonna
do the next day and counting your
calories and yeah well yeah it's very
cute I I've read so many articles about
working out last night wow and then I
pulled my back today so there you go 43.
dude
um what are you gonna do for uh bar bar
Barbie Barbie
are you having a stroke no I I I
understand why you say that but
barberheimer Oppenheimer nope Barbie and
Oppenheimer are coming out in the same
day oh did they come out already
so what are we going to do for
bargainheimer right is that what people
are calling it that's barberheimer yeah
okay
um I don't even know what you mean by
that what are we going to do for it
we're gonna see Barb no we're not
because we're gonna be in Vegas
carissa.com
we I don't want to see the Barbie movie
I don't care do I I don't see I don't so
let's go see upenheimer I want to see up
high but we'll probably wait till we
come back did you see what Christopher
Nolan said about
um the strike no he said he's not going
to make another movie until they figure
it out
yeah no [__] that's what a strike is I
know but I'm saying that oh you're on a
strike huh well check this out I won't
make another movie until the strike ends
no but like he's putting his back in the
game skin in the game and being like I'm
not going to work again until you do
this this and this I understand that but
he's trying to get credit off of
something that everyone is already doing
and he's saying it in a different way
when realized all he should be saying is
I stand with them because I'm striking
he's lost me as a fan no but he's
kidding I love his stuff it's cool
because you don't think about the actual
implications of it and he's putting
those implications to the Forefront
where like you're not gonna see another
one of my movies until I make rad movies
until we get what we want which is
can you look this up I mean what's he
talking about I don't know money and
money and I mean the AI thing I think
that honestly what I think with this
this writer strike and the actor strike
I think what they're doing is I think
because what they said about the
background actors and about how paying
them for a day for their likeness and
perpetuity I don't know I know what that
word means because I'm smart but like
perpetuity means forever but like so I
don't know why they just don't say and
so they use it forever they say in
perpetuity is not smart which is [__]
horseshit but I know it because I'm
smart so
um but why why do they well I think that
when they said that they were going to
do that they were just like well we
don't actually give a [__] about actors
and like we're not going to need them in
a little bit like I actually think that
actors are [__] I think writers are
[__] I think because in five years
you're gonna be able to make a dope
movie
and they're gonna have their own movie
stars that are fake not real and it's
going to look real and and it's going to
be great it's going to be gripping dude
and I think that Hollywood's gonna be
like we don't need Chris Pratt it's nice
to have them but we make way more money
without Chris Pratt because we don't
have to pay but
what do you have to say about that I
don't know I mean I'm thinking about it
logistically and I think there's
something to it being a real person like
you following their you're not just
watching it because it's they're a good
actor you're following it because
they're this I understand that I hear
that but but how until when how long
does that last I have no idea because
that's you know people love Chris Pratt
people love
Adam Driver but after they get old AI
what they'll just make a new movie star
the mcflimbot 75 and he'll be like
they'll be like starring flimbot75 I
mean grown ups 10 starring flimbot 75. I
have no idea what's gonna happen
obviously I don't think anyone does 10
is what I'm saying in like 10 years I
think it's going to be insane starring
[__] David Spade Chris Rock Kevin
James and flimbot77 and Adam Sandler
it's a flimbot 77 vehicle
oh oh my God we are grown-ups and we're
in a pool
oh my God we are grown-ups and we're
splashing
who peed in the pool Kevin James God
damn it Kevin James
if they asked you to do an all AI movie
I'm in dude I don't give a [__] about
this strike I'm in I'm in blackball me
I'm in I don't care I'm in an all AI
movie and it's also just me crystalia
babe we have so many actor friends [__]
them
[__] them dude [__] them to their face
how come though because I don't give a
[__] dude I'm getting that AI [__] you
want to be in the AI dude I am gangster
dude if you can't be like on the side
I'm acting to No One you can't be on the
side of the robot so that's like so not
the right way yeah I'm the bad guy I'm
the bad guy in the AI Wars don't say
that I wouldn't be with a good guy I
could be a politician and be the robot
[__] guy and we ought to have such a
great life babe we already have a great
life I know but we would have riches no
robots doing stuff if you didn't you
know if you don't want to do stuff I
could have the robots do it I don't mean
sexual but that too I don't mean sexual
I mean dishes dude I want the robots to
do the dish because I always have to do
the dishes that's the only tour that you
have and that's what you're recommending
the robots do in our house is your one
sure yeah
I like doing all my things you like
doing the dishes I don't do the dishes
you do the dishes what a politician that
was good dude you make a good first lady
thank you
um yeah dude I I just think that uh AI
is going to take over I think actors and
writers are [__] and I think that
people are afraid to say it and I'm not
afraid to say it I think that that's
what's gonna I think that that's what's
going to happen I think that they're
[__]
how do we help
oh we don't we can't it's impossible you
know how they go like this yeah But You
Gotta Die Trying you don't you can just
chill and and let it kill you yeah
you're gonna die anyway
I'm a nihilist
dude I what what you can't go against AI
you can't we're already it's it's
already done but we made it we can go
against whatever we want
my man
you know we should do on the podcast
a Thanos check-in no way
why I'm not doing that not on the
podcast because that's for us
I know but nowhere there's no way but
I'm saying before
we do a check-in you could tell them we
do the check okay so we do a check-in
every day this has been since rehab so
like what eight months yeah it's just
look you know it's like it's a it's
called Thanos you can look it up but I
think it could be really helpful for
people for people you always want to
help strangers you know me too me too
and what do you want to do work out
people laugh workout titties
sounds like a [__] awesome life it
would be so sad though I mean you were
doing that for quite a long time but yep
so Thanos checking okay it's four
couples
okay and I mean you're saying okay like
we don't do it every day
[Laughter]
and it's an acronym and
um for couples that are going through
hard things or fine anytime yeah anytime
it's like uh
um all the guys on the pie all the guys
on the podcast are going right now
they're going over to [__] listen to
Theo
go ahead
so F Thanos F is for feelings what
you're feeling that day oh simp
a affirmations I I
am worthy of love oh dude you're gonna
cry pick other ones that I don't say I'm
a good mom I don't say that one you
often say I'm a good dad I'm a good yeah
all right dude you don't have to air my
[__] out dude
okay you can cut that no it's fine leave
it but don't do any more of the things
that I do on that okay okay need of what
you need from your partner yeah I need
you to understand my PDA
um oh ownership things that you did that
were not so great that day oh my back
sucks no uh not like that like other
things well it could be I pulled my back
and now I'm pissed off and I let the
anger get to me yeah yeah
um s if you're in active recovery you
talk about your sobriety and and what
else
and then if you're not in recovery
self-care yeah so things that you did
for yourself
why'd I say safety and we added the G to
it okay yeah and then we do gratitude
things that we're grateful
and it's really helpful yeah and I
recommend it too it's hard for me any
and all couples yeah you've gotten good
at it yeah but it's hard though because
I I just don't want to be reminded that
um there are feelings
sure I don't dude I don't yeah I want to
play games I want to [__] I want to
work out I want to watch TV I want to
veg out dude I want to [__] uh Escape
Mary Riley remember that movie what they
would do that I didn't win the preview
is called Mary Riley and instead of it'd
be like Mary Riley would be like the
preview would be like
you know what we've been doing to escape
and it's so no cute to watch you dude
anymore
we've been playing this game called code
name oh [__] man I'm not a [__] and
this is the cutest thing me and David
Sullivan were playing together sitting
on the couch watching Chris play and we
were both like looking at him like our
little oh he's like enjoying himself and
like thinking about it that's so cute
the game ended I've never seen you so
into any kind of game ended and you were
going back and thinking of strategies
and things you could have said okay they
were like yeah and remember when you
said this and you were like oh you could
have done this and this and it was so
precious watching you be into something
none of that really happened though huh
you made it all up in your head and you
were like pacing the room and doing your
like
thing this yeah that's what I know
you're happy okay hold on let's let me
see the end of this
you're still on the Mary Riley thing I
mean it was good to tell him about the
game after him I just I just want to see
if they did that
that's so dumb wow dude
hey dude he brought it up from the
[__] archives From The Trenches man
Mary Riley
I want to hear it again
you put on your thing
put on your tape oh you don't have one
here I'll just play for you here
oh she [__] it up dude I'm so pissed
man this is just oh I can't put it
is it in no oh dude what's wrong with
you you got PDA okay
yeah
you know who I am
married right dude he remembers wow how
do I remember that [__] I can't remember
what color robe you had on this morning
um anyway she's a lonely servant of uh
in the home of Dr Jekyll and uh uh
devoted to her position as slowly
gradual friendship between Mary and the
doctor if he just wasn't going to talk
anyway it's a fantastic movie by uh
pictures uh it was made in like 19 it
says something but
um uh yeah speaking of YouTube uh
there's it I went on the uh you guys
should go check out on my crystalia
channel
um I did post it a half hour crowd work
there oh my God it's [__] spectacular
oh yeah you saw it oh thank you very
much this morning and I laughed so hard
really and you live with me so there you
go that's how I claim yeah it goes so
great go watch out uh get them numbers
up because we like to go dummy viral you
know what I mean oh yeah we like to go
stupid Whoopi viral can you talk about
the difference of like crowd work and
regular [__]
regular [__] just like material material
yeah yeah what would you want to know
um
like I feel like crowd work is in the
ethos right now like Matt Rife is yeah I
mean people it's so funny
Matt's great but every time someone like
becomes somebody that people notice that
does crowd work like they're like yo why
are you [__] jacking their style it's
like dude it was it used to be Andrew
Schultz and now it's Matt Rife it's like
dude everyone does crowd work when the
[__] crowd is nuts you just do it and
they're like this guy's trying to be
[__] this guy it's like dude like
everyone just does crowd work when the
[__] pops off and sometimes the ship
pops off and when it does I gotta make
sure that it [__] I can handle it and
you're doing business man because you
can find me in my place of business
Tupac said the best [__] huh extra paper
scoop that is a little Cool J but anyway
I just say stuff that you say oh cute
dude all right so what do you want to
know so the difference like crowd work
well crowd work is when you go into the
crowd and start asking crowd questions
and then work off the crowd through what
they say yeah I I know that part but
like it seems like magic so like what
are like okay I'm gonna tell people
right now this is what it well here's
what crowd work is yeah to me it's
flirting if you're not good at flirting
you can't do it you have to be able to
be comfortable enough with the opposite
sex or the same sex if you're into them
and confident enough to be able to crack
jokes with them if you can do that then
you can figure out how to do it on stage
uh because that's really all you're
doing is you're making fun of people in
a nice sweet joking way or you're
roasting them and which you can also do
that flirting wise too is called negging
right if you have to be good at flirting
then how are you so good at crowd work
[Music]
killed it dude you killed me see that
would be good groundwork thank you crowd
worker it's like me in the crowd so uh
uh
um
you you can't go oh to your own thing by
the way
I just did a baby
that black kid with the glasses stayed
in them the meme like in the sea of
people yeah yeah where they go no but
they do like this and then the one guys
like that yeah okay cool they say
library and ambulance but um so what
what uh yeah here's the actual uh truth
though and people I think comedians
don't like saying this because it it
people communities were good at crowd
work they wear it as a badge and it it
is definitely hard to do and it's
definitely a different thing like some
great comedians are horrible hard work
and some people are really good crowd
work and not the best comedians but I'm
gonna tell you right now generally
across the board crowd work is way
easier way easier than material is that
the general consensus yes absolutely and
comedians will will either not publicly
say that or it's not like a big thing I
mean [__] comedians some comedians
would say that but I feel like people
don't talk about that a lot because they
like to think their crowd work is badass
but dude it's so much harder to have
good material than it is to have good
crowd work because good passable crowd
work is if you can't do passable crowd
work you should never be on stage
because all you have to do is literally
be like hey nice jacket hey what's going
on there where'd you get that uh [__]
uh this this and then people like oh
he's making fun of the moment what's
happening right now that's so easy but
it does seem like magic it is well
because it's special for this time yeah
and it's special for us and people think
it's great when it's your friends and
then the people in the room that are in
the room with you are being made fun of
but to actual craft and I hate using
that word but to craft a joke five
minutes it's [__] I don't even I just
don't even know how comedians do it
it's so hard to do that yeah it is hard
um you know who does great crowd work I
haven't seen them in a long time but he
always makes me [__] loud Rick Ingram
Oh yeah he's yeah he's great well he's
like one of the best at it Izzy yeah
yeah yeah
he's so good at crowding him like coming
onto the stage yeah he's especially when
he would follow you he's great whatever
he would say he would follow me all the
time
uh I don't remember now he would say
something like I mean you're gonna have
to believe this but I just heard all the
[__] in the room drying yeah yeah
yeah yeah he would say that no no
they're leaving that that's that's kind
of nice so um so wait uh yeah he's
hilarious but he also
um but here's the other thing about
crowd work is
and I've said this before but like
Eminem
is amazing at rhyming like freestyling
and when you when you watch it you're
like how the [__] is he rhyming all
these words in real time but what you
don't realize is
he's already
thought of everything that has rhymed he
already knows so he's just pulling from
his database so they're so crowd work is
if you've done stand up long enough and
I've done it for 17 years if you've done
it long enough
you have situations that arise that have
been versions of things that you've been
dealing with for years so it's not like
it is still very impressive when a
person is if you crush with crowd work
that's impressive it is but
you're just picking from uh I've been
here before I'm comfortable enough oh
what's this person going to say [__] it
I know what to say because I've done
this before in [__] Wichita the same
kind of thing happened it's always a
little different but
um you get the stuff that you say and
you and you and you and you fired it off
it's kind of like material but it's not
though but I like to I like to you know
sometimes I do get into a rut I have
gotten into a rut before of saying the
same thing crowd work wise and I'm like
I gotta change that man because I'll
I'll like record it and then I'll be
like oh that's too much like this all
the time I don't want to post it so I
like try to like um
force myself to talk about different
things in crowd work which is what the
the one the half hour thing that I did
on my on my YouTube is uh is on right
now which is uh it's all it's all like
just off the cuff stuff I was in a crowd
with a bunch of gang members and [__] in
Pueblo Colorado and uh I mean that crowd
was [__] insane they were insane and
and no comedians go there and and it's
like yeah no comedians are gonna come
there if this is a [__] these are the
the people in the thing
but I was I was in the [__] one of
the reasons I did half an hour material
and then there was one dude just in the
back doing like this kind of thing and I
was like all right what what are you
saying bro I was just like dude I'm not
doing this for you guys didn't some guy
get stabbed outside of your show in uh
Oakland wow yep I have another comedy
question okay so this is something I
thought a lot about but I've never asked
you really yeah I don't know I I just we
spent a lot of time together sweetie I
know but we talk about other stuff that
we never really talk about comments
uh
uh so like
typically Comics will do their hour and
like perfect it for a couple of years at
least you're closer to like a year yeah
yeah but you know when you first tell a
joke on stage and you get that like yeah
that laugh of like first doing it
there's something to that and then doing
it over and over and over again do you
lose the magic of it and how do you keep
the Magic in a joke that you've told a
thousand times
it's hard uh sometimes because but
sometimes if I think a joke is really
funny I get excited to tell it most of
the time
you know what I'm saying okay like uh
if I especially if I know it's gonna it
pushes some of the audience members to
laugh or get or not not get offended but
like you know I mean I'm not here to
offend anybody I'm here to just but so
like I'll do the joke and I'm excited to
see how this audience will react to it
so there's that which you can still be
excited about it but often you'll do a
joke
like I told this one I did a new bit a
[__] a month ago I gotta
gotta do it in Vegas now coming up but
um I Heard it four or five new minutes
no and um
and uh it crushed and the second time
you do it it'll bomb
it's just I don't know because because I
think that that's the most time you're
trying to you're not speaking from your
truth you're trying to recreate what you
did oh and so you need to get past that
and then try and
um
just uh
try and just uh find the excitement in
it but I I'm I I'm I think I'm
particularly like it's it's I'm I think
I'm good at that like I like to find the
excitement because it's exciting for me
I think it's hilarious that I'm even
doing stand up like all the time so like
when I'm on stage I'm so happy
and uh you know I used to like try to
not laugh because I was having fun I was
like I shouldn't laugh but then I was
like why am I trying to not I was like
I'm having so much fun [__] I'm gonna
laugh and then like people will be like
I like your laugh so I'm like all right
[__] I'll just do it
you know
um but yeah it it can it can you can
lose like sometimes I'm like I'm sick of
this joke like I toured Man on Fire for
two years and I was like dude
I have to film this like this I'm so I
should have filmed this six months ago
and now I'm like I didn't want to do it
um with this one I filmed it in eight
months I mean very quick so I think it
was right there well this new one that I
did is the best thing that I've done but
like I'm so excited for it to come out
but that was fun but right now like also
when I have it in the can when I'm when
it's done I know it's filmed I want to
do new [__] so like I'm just getting so
bored of doing it and I'm so excited
what's next
you know me too yeah we don't say me too
anymore say same but um
same yeah
Army also
what was the thing that um
when we were at dinner that thing that
our buddy said and then I was like we
have to remember that thing that he said
it was so wise yep I do remember that
moment what the hell was it
oh [__] were we at dinner oh yeah yeah
we were with our buddy we went to Malibu
with yeah yeah
our buddies yeah and uh hold on and so
what did he say he did he said something
it was very wise
and we forgot because we are dummies no
I told you to write it down
no I don't remember that even oh God I
can ask him James what did you say that
was so wise
this is gonna be the worst moment of
podcast history because we're both not
gonna remember
it was the Wilderness wandering no it
was around that time when he was talking
about the wilderness
wow this is so dumb we can cut it right
yeah we can cut it but we're not going
to because I want people to see you hang
out to dry
uh what the hell was it it was because I
thought it was smart too and you thought
it was right how dumb are [__]
you know you were like that's so smart I
was like yeah that's in my own head I
was like that's so smart later on you're
like you know we got to remember that
and we're like yeah and then we just go
and it just goes
here we go
[Laughter]
dude
what was it
well speaking of the mic we'll do this
wandering
no it was God if you're with us man you
ever do that [__] you know what you're
saying what was it babe uh Google what
my friend said man no I don't know we're
not gonna remember text him he's not
gonna I don't want to
I'm putting my foot down [__] oh I'll
text him after the podcast and maybe I
know but like it was so meaningful and I
feel like it could have impacted us and
then we'll never remember no we will not
never remember we will remember sweetie
we'll never remember we'll remember
because it was important it was it was
it was a long thing and then a quick
thing
it was like a sentence and then another
quick one I mean why are you looking at
them I thought that they were like
I don't know why anyway enough of that
you know but it is what it is oh that's
what it was it is what it is
um
what else you want to talk about
whatever no come on
um we have two kids now yeah yeah
they're [__] so cool it's so fun
William looks a little bit like you but
also like me in the eyes
and Calvin looks like me
oh I know what I want to talk about well
I have a book club now oh yeah and you
guys should join yay totally It's called
The Cozy Road book club cute dude and
it's on Goodreads Goodreads is an app
that you can get that you go on that I
have book clubs on it yep uh how's that
going for you it's going really good
you're part of the book club I am on it
I can't remember I can't figure out how
to post
wow
um but I wanna but I wanna post I always
want to reply to people's comments and I
can't it's cute yeah you have to show me
how to do it it's really really amazing
there have been some really cool
vulnerable sweet shares and I feel
really lucky
I'm a simp just anyone Sim seems like a
great thing it's simple it's cool I
think simple is cool simple if you SIM
for somebody you're kind of the [__]
yeah like yo it's like you're like the
guy in like the 1600s were like I will
do anything for you my love I will
travel long distances for something that
might
make you coughless
in these dreary times how long would you
travel for me
if you had to walk how far would you
walk for me
six blocks
I go like this oh man I should have
turned back two blocks ago
when I come back I'd be all sweaty I'd
be like babe I love you but I don't know
what did you want I'd do that
wait no we gotta talk about your your
book club oh that's it no but also
I have a cool logo right it is cool and
if you're on Goodreads check it out but
I want to know something about this
because it's awesome because you wake up
and you wake up before the kids get up
sometimes yeah and you read yeah and
then you post about it yeah and that's
amazing and that is something that I
love about you because it's awesome
and it makes you happy dude doing
something when you wake up that makes
you happy is like you got like man
remember someone's talking about waking
up I was I follow this guy on Instagram
I can't remember what his name is but
it's his workout he's a workout guy and
he's like I wake up every morning the
same thing I drink I down a whole bottle
of water and I go outside for 20 minutes
I do not look at my phone first I do
that and then I can go to business if I
want to and I was like man that's such a
good idea
um and I did that one time so far but I
only read it like a week ago okay yeah
um
the sun feels so good huh
well right now it's real hot but yes
being outside is something that we need
I know I always think back to like our
original caveman people and what were
they doing what were our bodies meant to
be doing and we do so much different
stuff we were meant to be doing though
constantly because I could drag it by
the hair constantly being outside
sweetie you know what they used to do I
mean we were never inside you know I
know
um
not even paying attention to the humor
and I'm doing it for free and I get paid
to do it but it's all good you want to
talk about what we used to see this is
what we talk about you always want to
talk about something serious so what is
it what is it just don't you think we
should do what our caveman people did
yeah I would be naked a lot more
yeah sure I would just wear one of those
things over my thing well you'd be a
hunter
and I'd be gathering into Lynn oh my god
dude I come back everything will be
rearranging the Hut again I'd be like I
would be like
and you'd be like and I'd be like
yeah
yeah but I think there is something too
waking up early and and doing something
that you like yes especially pre-karts
like getting in if I wake up and you
don't mean pre-kids before you have kids
you mean before the kids yes like before
my kids wake up I get my own coffee
I have time to myself reading by myself
what do you mean get my own coffee like
we don't split coffee
I'm saying like if cow were downstairs I
would get his milk first I would get him
set up okay and I'm just like
immediately tending to my own needs got
it I guess a mom that's so not typically
what you do you do that like three
percent of the day what 10 to your own
needs yeah yeah you know
um
but yeah it's been really nice and I
feel like I'm a better parent when I
have that time yeah because I start the
day you're not resentful not not that
you were resentful you never resentful
with the kids I mean you love you being
a mom is your number one yeah yeah
resentful isn't the word but I feel like
um balance like aligned
oh you know what we can talk about oh
God
we
are oh God we might do psychedelics
this is the new thing dude yo chicks be
crazier than a [__] man I swear
to God
first of all let's say it for real you
decided that you might want to do
psychedelics and that's where it ends
I'm not saying I won't but she had me
have a conversation with one of the
people that is from the company that by
the way the [__] phone call cost 49
and she was just like so you want to do
psychedelics and I was like I don't know
maybe what's up she told me a little bit
about it anything I could have Googled
and I coulda I watched you on the phone
call and you were like this
yeah did you did you do it was it okay
did you feel okay she made me sound like
a [__]
I am not but you were like hard on the
phone you were like I know open and
sweet see this is why people think I'm a
dick because you don't understand that
I'm not always in podcast mode sure yeah
right yeah
yeah I never see this side of you
it's like you're on fire like you're
electric when you're on here you're like
in electricity mode you gotta you gotta
uh and then the other half of the day
you're asleep
dude you nap so much you know what I
haven't been napping lately at all and
you know why because I've been working
out that's why really yeah it gives more
energy huh and the perspective CBD is
nice
and Magic mind yeah magic mind is great
I've been feeling better doing you've
been doing the magic mind yeah that's
why we ran out so okay it's all good
you've been giving away
um but yeah we had calls and it's a
five-week program and you do two
sessions prior to taking whatever you
want whether it be mushrooms or
Ayahuasca and then the third week you do
it at our house which would be amazing
and you go through the whole six to
eight hour ceremony and then I don't
like that they call it a ceremony I
don't think they actually do I think
they call it a session okay
um and then you have two Zoom wrap-up
calls and that kind of thing I don't
want to be doing but the whole thing is
you have to like integrate it
integration is so important it's like 50
of it is the operation yeah and then you
talk about what you learned and
see how it can fit into your real life
your brain is so beautiful thank you and
it's right it's narrow rigid yeah rigid
I want to do mushrooms and I'm just
gonna be like
what are your fears I don't have I I I
at this point in my life I've been open
to a lot of change so I don't really
have that I don't really have fears
really the only thing I mean our kids
have no fear about it but like I I I
don't
I the the one thing that I don't
like is that it will take up a whole day
and I've never done drugs so I don't
know if I want to break that
even though it is is it just on
principle yeah really it's also but it's
also not it's it's not like it's
prescribed but it is like it's not like
I'm recreational recreationally doing
drugs probably yeah but uh someone
that's
yeah
but uh
yeah I'm not yeah but at this point it's
just like another you know I don't like
to do things
is it working out is it stand up
is I'm sorry he's doing mushrooms
working out he's doing mushrooms stand
up is doing mushrooms making love to you
oh it's three mushrooms it's doing
mushrooms hanging out with my children
no those are the four things I do is
doing mushrooms getting coffee I coffee
beanie Tilly for Pete's no
it's just a new thing that I don't want
to do and add to my life because I like
five things and if I like anything more
then I can do those five things as much
you have autism PDA type
[Laughter]
I hope you do I might I might do it you
never know
God you on mushrooms I can't even
imagine like I feel like the I feel like
you can start floating you know what you
can't imagine is me on coke
dude I would be so extra me it would be
[__] dude I bet I would be you know
what I bet I I bet my price would go up
so I would start selling out Arenas dude
if I did Coke and went to do a show you
know how on [__] fire I'd be you know
how mocked had I brought me Mach 11. I'd
be out there what I would pay to not
have to be in the building with you and
another thing and another thing is are
we like that and they'd be like does
another thing
you think it would make you a better
comic no no you don't think no I'm
finding her for about five minutes yeah
and then the world would explode
anyway that's good for this I really
enjoyed having you on time I thought we
were rolling into two it's long no it's
an hour and eight minutes I think it's
been cool
um that's not too long because we cut
alert for the patreon but anyway
um I appreciate you guys uh I'm gonna be
on chrysalia.com I'm gonna be doing a
lot of different dates I'm gonna be in
Vegas this weekend I'm gonna be in Brea
and Irvine Orange County I'm going to be
in Charlotte uh North Carolina I'm going
to be in Little Rock Arkansas I'm going
to be in Nashville as she said she'll be
at the wedding but I'll be in Nashville
and we got the pocket stay deep tees
right here chrisley.com
and get that stuff and then also join
her book club if you're into reading
um and talk about your feelings and all
that stuff uh go to book it's on
Goodreads the app Goodreads right yep
yep and she's running it dude run it run
it on out run it run it
oh I got fans you got friends they're on
your book club now and then at
christmas.com okay well uh you can leave
but I'll keep doing the Chris Brown
stuff that's it for the YouTube version
if you want to watch the patreon version
the unedited the extra long version of
this episode go on over to patreon.com
crystallia and then also you get the uh
extra episode a month and there's also a
tour report on there that I didn't
upload to the public but there's a bunch
of little things over there so go to
chrysalia.com or I'm sorry go to
patreon.com crystalia and sign up for
the patreon thanks very much my babies
[Music]
thank you